merci beaucoup Alain joliand d'aide de
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur les républicains de
la Haute-Saône on va évidemment parler
de cette réforme des retraites et
d'abord ce message adressé hier par
Emmanuel Macron via l'AFP il a souhaité
que la réforme puisse aller au bout de
son cheminement démocratique dans le
respect de tous c'est le bon message
dans le climat de tension actuelle
pas certains que ce soit le bon message
ni le bon moment mais enfin déjà depuis
le début c'est comme ça je pense que la
réforme des retraites si elle est
nécessaire n'est pas n'a pas été
présentée dans les bonnes circonstances
peut-être pas au bon moment non plus
enfin bon est-ce que c'est le bon moment
pour réformer si jamais trop le bon
moment toujours est-il que sur le fond
des choses si on parle de la démocratie
respect des institutions on peut pas on
ne peut pas contester que le 49.3 même
si sur un texte comme ça il peut
apparaître comme une provocation en tout
cas c'est ce qu'un certain nombre de
personnes disent toujours est-il que cet
article là fait partie de nos
institutions et que c'est grâce à cet
article là qu'un gouvernement qui est
soutenu par une majorité seulement
relative peut faire passer un certain
nombre de textes
de déclencher pour vous avez dit sur ce
plateau il y a 8 jours qu'il s'était la
seule solution quand on y est on y est
maintenant qu'on est dans cette
situation il faut bien en sortir et donc
il n'avait pas d'autre solution est-ce
que c'était est-ce que c'était
[Musique]
une façon de redonner un peu d'oxygène
et de de paisibilité au pays c'est
peut-être malgré une adoption du texte
au fond par défaut c'est peut-être de
tourner la page et de d'essayer de
reconstruire quelque chose je pense
qu'il faut regarder le jour d'après pour
essayer de reconstruire quelque chose
sur de nouvelles bases avec à mon avis
une urgence qui est
urgence sociale il y a beaucoup trop de
gens dans ce pays qui ne peuvent plus
vivre de leur travail c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont dans la rue je parle pas des
excès de la violence tout ce que je
condamne évidemment fortement mais tous
ceux qui qui sont dans la rue ne sont
pas des violents il y a ceux il y a
beaucoup d'entre eux qui travaillent et
qui ne peuvent pas s'en sortir donc pour
moi il y a une urgence sociale il faut
donner du pouvoir d'achat et
reconstruire avec la République c'est la
question on en parle tout de suite de
votre partie puisque des députés les
républicains excluent pas de voter
l'émotion de censure présenter cet
après-midi à l'encontre la consigne
direction-t-il président du parti on
fait le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Alain Juan
Alain j'ai la censure du gouvernement
elle dépend des députés les républicains
qui sont divisés sur la question
effectivement Oriane mathématiquement
pour que le gouvernement soit censuré il
faut qu'une trentaine de députés les
républicains votent en faveur d'une des
deux motions de censure qui ont été
déposer on le rappelle le groupe LR à
l'Assemblée est composé de 61 députés et
le patron du parti exotique a donné et
bien une ligne directrice hors de
question de voter l'ascension du
gouvernement
ça veut dire qu'on va gouverner en
alternative au pays et dans les
signataires de la motion de censure que
certains auraient pu voter il y a les
amis de Monsieur Mélenchon et puis je le
dis non il y aura très peu de députés
républicains ils seront quelques
quelques-uns mais très faibles l'immense
majorité du groupe ne votera pas
derrière moi cette motion de censure
alors effectivement il y a quand même
quelques députés les républicains qui
ont annoncé qu'ils allaient voter la
motion de censure transpartiz déposée
par le groupe liott liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire quelques députés
LRP pas plus d'autant que le député du
Lot Aurélien Pradier selon les
informations du journal Le Figaro Orient
Pradier qui est cristallisé quand même
l'opposition d'une partie de des députés
LR à cette réforme des retraites et bien
finalement il ne votera pas la motion de
censure alors quelques voix des députés
LR c'est insuffisant pour faire passer
cette notion de censure mais pour
gonfler ce chiffre et bien le patron du
rassemblement national Jordan Bardella a
fait une offre en faveur des députés LR
qui seraient notamment craintif d'une
future dissolution de l'Assemblée
nationale qui aurait peur en 400 sur
deux gouvernement et après de
dissolution et bien de remettre en jeu
leur mandat de voir les électeurs et
bien Jordan Bardella elle a dit en cas
de dissolution de l'Assemblée le
rassemblement national ne présentera pas
de candidats dans les circonscriptions
ou les députés LR voteront la motion de
censure ça c'est l'offre faite par le RN
elle la réponse du patron du groupe LR à
l'Assemblée Olivier marlex les dép ne
sont pas à vendre à linge landais
qu'est-ce que vous dites assez députés
les républicains ils sont pour l'instant
quelques-uns qui vont voter la motion de
censure ils ont raison ils sont libres
l'esprit de la motion de censure quand
on la vote c'est qu'on a un gouvernement
de remplacement une majorité de
remplacement c'est ça le prix de la
Constitution aussi voter la motion c'est
bien mais après ça pose la question avec
qui on peut gouverner est-ce qu'on a une
majorité de remplacement nous n'avons
pas de majorité de remplacement donc le
mieux c'est de s'en tenir au texte la
réforme des retraites ceux qui sont
vraiment très hostiles à cette réforme
vauteront la censure ils seront
quelques-uns
chez les LR ça ne suffira pas pour voter
la censure et faire tomber le
gouvernement ça sera un peu anecdotique
et j'ai envie de dire au bout du compte
tout ça pour ça c'est combien
quelques-uns vous savez combien de
députés
il en faudrait beaucoup plus je suis pas
je peux pas deviner mais en tout cas il
en faudrait beaucoup plus que ceux qui
ont l'intention de la voter pour faire
tomber le gouvernement et faire tomber
le texte restons en hautex ce sera plus
facile et puis voilà il y aura surtout
les textes sur tous les textes dans tous
les partis il y a toujours un moment
donné quelques quelques parlementaires
en conscience en conscience qui décide
de de voter contre ou de ne pas voter
sans s'abstance la question ici
précisément c'est quelle est la
conséquence politique de d'un tel acte
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait après et quelle
est la conséquence politique pour eux
est-ce qu'ils doivent être exclus du
parti et du groupe s'il vote l'ascenseur
moi je suis pas je suis pas fanatique
des exclusions à chaque fois qu'on a
exclu on s'en est très mal porté je
pense qu'il est temps que les
républicains se remettent autour de la
table puisque vous savez 61 députés à
l'Assemblée nationale avec ce nombre on
est on est le groupe pivot c'est-à-dire
on fait passer où on fait pas passer les
textes si on se divise on n'est plus
rien
on n'est plus rien puisqu'on ne sera
plus assez pour peser pour apporter
faire en sorte que la majorité relative
devienne majorité tout court absolu au
moment du vote de tel ou de tel texte si
nous nous des visons et bien nous ne
pouvons plus jouer ce rôle donc je suis
pas un partisan de l'exclusion mais au
contraire dans cette période de tension
je pense que la responsabilité des
dirigeants c'est au contraire d'essayer
de rassembler de se mettre d'accord sur
une ligne politique c'est de ça dont il
faut parler certains alors il y a la
question de la motion transpartisane
portée par note mais certains n'exclut
pas de voter la motion portée par le
rassemblement national ça c'est une
ligne rouge pour vous je crois que c'est
une ligne rouge mais je pense que pour
le coup pour le coup ils ne seront pas
très nombreux mais encore une fois
posons-nous la question nous les
républicains
quel service peut-on rendre à la France
dans les quatre ou cinq ans qui viennent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on
contribue à ajouter une crise politique
ou bien est-ce que on est en
responsabilité justement face à toutes
ces divisions des députés les
républicains sur la réforme des
retraites certains sont pour certains
sont contre certains demandaient des
améliorations qui étaient et bien et les
concessions n'étaient pas suffisantes
selon vous est-ce que ça apportait
atteinte à la crédibilité DLR comme
partie de gouvernement je pense qu'il
est temps de se ressaisir sur ce plan
partie le gouvernement oui donc si on
est un parti de gouvernement il faut
qu'on en tire les conséquences on est
dans une on est dans un moment politique
où on n'a pas on n'a pas trois
alternatives on en a deux effectivement
on vote la censure on fait tomber le
gouvernement et après on fait des
alliances que beaucoup condamnent voilà
et puis l'autre solution c'est de dire
on est un parti de gouvernement voyons
après ce texte sur les retraites voyons
si nous avons la capacité de participer
à une œuvre de reconstruction et de ne
pas à la crise sociale une crise
politique une crise de régime en quelque
sorte donc moi je pense qu'il faut que
toutes les hypothèses soient sur la
table et que les républicains en parlent
et que l'on voit ce que l'on peut faire
est-ce que pour le dire clairement à
l'agendais vous souhaitez un accord de
gouvernement avec Emmanuel Macron avec
le ou la future première ligne je pense
qu'on responsabilité on ne peut rien
refuser pour l'instant comme ça de but
en blanc s'il y avait s'il y avait toute
façon pour moi il faut un changement de
gouvernement je pense que c'est même si
la motion même si alors après c'est le
président de la République c'est pas
c'est vraiment le président de la
République mais je pense que apaiser ce
serait ça même vous savez je pense que
même si le texte avait été voté
imaginons qu'il y ait pas eu le 49-3 je
suis persuadé que si le texte avait été
voté il l'aurait été peut-être avec une
voix deux voix trois voix d'avance
est-ce que vous pensez que ça aurait
changé quoi que ce soit dans la rue
absolument pas je pense que la
légitimité du du texte aurait été
contestée quand même parce que
il faudrait un Premier ministre qui soit
capable de rassembler voilà qui qui
viennent de tel ou tel endroit je sais
pas mais en tout cas une personnalité
qui soit capable de rassembler pour moi
le problème c'est pas monsieur Macron
monsieur Macron est dans 4 ans dans 4
ans il sera plus là la question c'est
comment est-ce que avec d'un côté et les
filles la gauche extrême gauche de
l'autre côté l'extrême droite comment
est-ce que la droite républicaine est le
centre se reconstitue pour assurer
l'avenir notre pays et si de tenter le
redressement de notre pays il faudra
bien aussi une réconciliation il
faudrait bien une réconciliation mais il
faudrait bien une réconciliation que
avec avec tous ceux qui sont
historiquement de la droite républicaine
et du centre on peut pas on peut il
faudra bien un moment
Bruno Le Maire évidemment mais
évidemment que ce que feront les
républicains seuls est-ce que vous
croyez que c'est une dissolution on sera
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce qu'on a un leader aujourd'hui qui
soit capable d'incarner un leader en
place en action qui soit capable
d'incarner une éventuelle alternative à
l'Élysée pour l'instant on est on est je
pense je pense je pense qu'en ce moment
on est dans dans la survie je parle pas
de ce qui se passe au Sénat au scénario
une majorité autour du président Larcher
c'est autre chose qui est bien plus
large que les républicains je parle
quand même de la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est quand même un moment
donné c'est de là dont provient le
Premier ministre pour vous le futur
leader des républicains c'est un de ceux
qui est actuellement au gouvernement
qu'il a été comme Édouard Philippe et
qui a quitté votre famille je dis pas ça
je dis simplement que j'essaie d'être
logique
peu importe celui qui c'est pas ça la
question pour l'instant la question
est-ce qu'on reconstitue une majorité de
la droite du Centre vous me parlez des
parties de gouvernement pour éviter d'un
côté on a déjà eu ce problème au
présidentiel est-ce qu'il ce qui fait
que le problème a pas été résolu c'est
que Monsieur Macron l'a fait un peu trop
tout seul et que du coup il a une
majorité qui n'est pas une majorité
absolue mais si un moment donné
comment dire quand les fossés sont créés
il faut un certain temps pour les pour
les boucher pour retrouver les gens tous
ensemble mais moi je ne vois pas on a
trois ans devant nous c'est c'est plus
beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup donc je vois
pas comment on peut redonner à notre
pays une force politique républicaine de
la droite et du centre si un moment
donné on ne rassemble pas tous ceux qui
sont de cette sensibilité alors c'est un
gros travail vous me direz c'est
peut-être j'espère ne pas être dans
l'utopie voilà mais j'essaie de regarder
les choses d'une manière la plus logique
possible et je pense qu'il faut tendre
la main je crois qu'on peut pas
continuer le la situation de notre pays
est trop difficile pour continuer à
faire des bisbilles politiciennes c'est
une position qui est majoritaire ou
minoritaire au sein du groupe au Sénat
par exemple et au sein de votre partie
je pense que je suis pas majoritaire non
je pense que ceux qui pensent ça ne sont
pas majoritaires mais à un moment donné
il faut bien quand même où il y a de
plus on a entendu Rachida Dati dire la
même chose que vous est-ce qu'il y a des
voix qui s'élèvent
et à un moment donné et on peut pas
rester camoufler il faut quand même
mettre quelques idées sur la table on en
discute voilà je dis pas que c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga mais peut-être qu'il
faut quand même en discuter pour ne pas
fermer les portes parce que si on ferme
les portes je vois pas d'issue donc je
ne vois pas d'autre issues que celle de
la discussion pour essayer de retrouver
une majorité et de permettre
éventuellement éventuellement un
monsieur Macron d'aller au bout de son
quinquennat 11 dissoudre l'Assemblée
nationale parce que aussi bien pour le
pays que pour notre force politique une
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale je
ne pense pas que c'est vrai quelque
chose de positif pour la France
veut comme votre leader c'est Laurent
Wauquiez qu'on n'entend pas vous
regrettez son silence dans cette période
mais son retrait pour l'instant et fait
partie de de ma réflexion et de ce que
je propose aujourd'hui si on avait à la
tête des républicains un nouveau leader
qui se qui se soit fait élire qui soit
aujourd'hui celui qui incarne le le
l'alternative à l'Elysée la
problématique serait différente mais on
va pas recommencer comme la dernière
fois je vous rappelle que la dernière
fois on a mis un président des
républicains qui attendaient qu'un
leader se lève il sait jamais levé
résultat des courses on a investi
quelqu'un six mois avant les élections
qui ont fait moins de 5%, est-ce qu'on
recommence
à décrédibiliser Laurent woquée
je veux pas dire que ça décrébine
mais bien sûr que si et d'ailleurs
l'éventuelle stratégie d'une
reconstitution de la droite et du centre
n'empêche pas bien au contraire Laurent
Wauquiez d'être le moment où il le
décidera celui qui peut incarner parce
que si on réconcilie les gens on ne fait
pas de on exclu personne et chacun un
moment donné peut participer à la à la
compétition mais il y a deux choses pour
moi c'est c'est reconstituer les forces
et puis l'autre chose c'est un
calendrier serré on peut pas recommencer
attendre deux ans avant une
présidentielle pour avoir quelqu'un de
crédible et qui soit préparé vous savez
pour être président de la République il
faut prendre des coups il faut accepter
de perdre des élections en gagner après
être un peu cabossé les gens aiment
comme encore bien ça et quand on est
prêt on est prêt en tout cas dans ce
contexte les élus les républicains font
l'objet de pression ils sont pris pour
cible ce weekend la permanence à Nice a
été caillassée avec la menace suivante
la motion ou le pavé à l’injolandais
vous créez vous craignez cette montée
des violences contre les élus mais bien
sûr et ça ne et ça n'est pas à mettre au
passif des forces syndicales ni des
manifestants de base qui ont manifesté
dans un grand calme sont des extrémistes
qui se servent des manifestations pour
en rajouter et voilà évidemment que je
condamne et que j'ai une pensée pour
Éric Ciotti qui est quelqu'un de
responsable qui ne mérite pas pas plus
que n'importe quel autre parlementaire
de quelques parties que ce soit je pense
que on est dans un pays quand même
démocratique civilisé alors certes il y
a des tensions il y a des inquiétudes
enfin rien de justifie une telle une
telle violence psychologiquement qui
n'est pas facile à supporter pour un
éluance des parlementaires vous-même
vous avez été victime de pression de
menaces non mais bon mon préfet ne m'a
prévenu que que évidemment il y avait
une surveillance comme pour tous les
par le menteur non nous dans notre dans
nos départements heureusement nous
n'avons pas nous n'avons pas connu ça
comment s'est passé le week-end dans
votre
circonscriptions comme tout comme
partout j'allais dire avec un nombre de
personnes quand même significatif il y a
il y a un certain calme quand même on
n'est pas dans les départements les plus
les plus tendus
sur cette période
mon boucher me dit mais on en peut plus
c'est pas que le salarié c'est tout le
monde qui n'en peut plus voyez dans un
pays où le les gens n'arrivent plus à
vivre de leur salaire avec des pressions
de pression fiscale une pression des
prélèvements qui sont énormes donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est bien au-delà du
problème des retraites on a un problème
de pouvoir d'achat pour tout le monde et
surtout pour les gens qui travaillent
juste un mot pour vous dire que nous on
a 3000 salariés Peugeot en Haute-Saône
les salariés Peugeot ont reçu il y a
quelques semaines une prime de de 4000
euros
parce qu'il y a un partage des beaucoup
d'entreprises le font de partage des
bénéfices bon mais c'est là qu'il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin et moi j'ai des
propositions très concrètes à faire sur
ce sujet là c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui et moi je propose que sur
les bénéfices des entreprises il y a un
tiers pour les actionnaires il y a un
tiers pour les salariés et puis un tiers
pour les investissements futurs à
financer voilà des grandes réformes que
l'on pourrait faire les républicains
doivent proposer des choses pour sortir
de la crise et vous pensez que vous
pensez que justement le gouvernement va
encore pouvoir mener des grandes des
grandes réformes dans ce quinquennat ou
que le quinquennat est paralysé il
pourra pas le faire et je pense qu'il y
a besoin il pourra pas le faire seul je
pense qu'il y a besoin aujourd'hui de
d'avoir quasiment un gouvernement
d'union nationale pour sortir de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
merci Alex à tout à l'heure on reparle
notion de censure évidemment avec vous
et on va continuer à parler de cette
réforme de retraite et des mobilisations
contre cette réforme des retraites on
l'a dit dans plusieurs villes de France
ce weekend dont Marseille où on retrouve
les hauts purgate bonjour Léo merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous président et
directeur éditorial de La Marseillaise
et les hauts vous revenez sur l'état de
la mobilisation dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône
oui dans les Bouches-du-Rhône et plus
largement dans notre région où de
nombreux rassemblements et
manifestations sont déroulés tout le
week-end à Marseille vous l'avez dit
mais également à Avignon à Toulon à
Saint-Raphaël ou c'est absolument
inédit et donc effectivement nous sommes
allés prendre le pouls de la
manifestation et également des secteurs
stratégiques qui sont en grève il faut
savoir que dans les Bouches-du-Rhône 25%
des stations services manquent d'essence
et donc la pénurie commence à se faire
sentir de manière très importante il y a
également des perturbations qui se
poursuivent dans les transports à la
SNCF mais également à l'aéroport
Marseille Provence ou on attend 20% de
vol supprimer il y a également les
manifestations et mobilisations qui
s'organisent autour
du baccalauréat aujourd'hui la question
que je voulais poser à votre invité
monsieur je regardais c'est évidemment
cette défiance qui atteint des records
l'Ifop nous explique que la cote
d'alerte est atteinte par pour le
président de la République avec y
compris son socle d'électorat de premier
tour qui est fissuré est-ce que dans ce
contexte de défiance générale vous
n'allez pas apparaître comme ceux qui
veulent sauver le camp présidentiel moi
il me semble que ce qu'il faut sauver
c'est notre pays c'est la France 3000
milliards de dettes une inquiétude
vraiment au sommet vous le dites très
justement qui est mesuré dans les études
d'opinion qui se succèdent et qui sont
toutes les mêmes et les choses ne
s'arrangent pas c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut peut-être un
électrochoc politique et social et si on
peut et si on peut trouver un
électrochoc et politique et social qui
évite la le passage par la crise
politique voir la crise de régime je
pense que les républicains ont un rôle à
jouer je disais tout à l'heure le
problème c'est pas de savoir si on sauve
le soldat Macron ou si on le sauve pas
ou si on l'aide la question c'est est-ce
que dans ce moment précis est-ce que un
parti de de gouvernement comme le note
je rappelle quand même issu
issu du général de Gaulle quand même
c'est notre héritage est-ce que on se on
se campe dans des tranchées politiques
où est-ce qu'on essaie de participer
quel que soit les commentaires qui
seront peut-être désagréables pour nous
mais est-ce qu'on essaie de participer
au redressement de notre pays voilà donc
c'est comme ça je n'ai je ne dis pas que
que j'ai la réponse mais je pense qu'on
peut pas ne pas se poser au moins la
question parce que c'est notre devoir
vous craignez une radicalisation c'est
mobilisations en cas d'adoption de la
réforme cet après-midi la radicalisation
on la voit déjà donc elle est là la
question c'est ce qu'elle va s'amplifier
ou est-ce que elle va petit à petit
décélérer ça je lis pas dans le marc de
café et autant je peux vous dire à peu
près sûr que la motion de censure sera
pas votée quels seront les conséquences
ça je peux pas dire je souhaite je
souhaite que le Président de la
République fasse ce qu'il faut faire
pour éteindre l'incendie avant que tout
soit embrasé
les syndicats Jean-Luc Mélenchon dire
mais même si la réforme est adoptée on
continuera à appeler à son retrait il y
a eu l'exemple du CPE on continuera à
mener la bataille oui enfin Monsieur
Mélenchon on sait quels sont ces
objectifs donc à l'Assemblée nationale
ils ont fait en sorte qu'on qu'il n'y
ait pas de vote il y a pas eu de vote à
l'Assemblée nationale on a failli avoir
le même problème au Sénat heureusement
ça ne s'est pas passé au Sénat parce que
évidemment il y a des procédures qui
sont un petit peu différentes et une
major donc autour du président du Sénat
mais Monsieur Mélenchon lui veut le
chaos il veut il veut entre guillemets
la crise de régime ne le ne le gène pas
puisque lui il souhaite un changement de
régime nous les républicains est-ce
qu'on veut un changement de régime je
crois pas donc justement il faut qu'on
ait une attitude très différente qui
s'est passé au Parlement n'est pas
démocratique on est dans une procédure
autoritaire tempérée dit-il oui mais
enfin la procédure autoritaire tempérée
elle est dans les institutions je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je pense que la
réforme des retraites elle a été mal
engagée une fois qu'on y est on y est
bon donc il fallait bien aller au bout
ou peut-être que le Président de la
République peut décider comme ça a été
le cas du CPE à un moment donné de de
retirer un texte qui a été voté ou de ne
pas le promulguer il est dans nos dans
nos je dis pas qu'il va le faire je
pense qu'il veut je pense que ce serait
c'est à mon avis c'est très difficile
qui l'avait entendu l'appel encore en
retrait du texte mais bien sûr mais je
pense que l'enjeu pour notre pays est
tellement important sur la scène
internationale pour tout y compris et
pour l'intérêt pour le la gouvernance de
notre pays ce serait difficile vous
savez sur les déficits
ou retraite on dit on ne donne pas
vraiment les vrais chiffres on est plus
entre 20 et 30 milliards d'euros qui
sont financés chaque année par des
emprunts est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte que l'on fait des emprunts sur la
tête de nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants pour financer les
retraites des actuels retraités c'est ça
la situation financière de notre pays
mais qu'il explique est-ce que vous
l'entendez non les Français ont une
personne ne leur explique au contraire
capables que le corps dit ceci ou cela
et que c'est une réforme
inutile alors je pense que
fondamentalement c'est une réforme
absolument indispensable et là elle a
été très mal gérée merci Alain joyeux
merci Léo d'avoir été avec nous motion
de censure défiance générale
avait gagné donc vous devez être
particulièrement particulièrement
satisfait vous avez le général derrière
vous alors je vais passer une très bonne
journée aujourd'hui vous êtes Président
je préside l'Association des gaullistes
donc dans mon département voilà et dans
ma famille j'ai quelques supporters
inconditionnels de l'OM qui vient de
consolider sa deuxième place voilà et
c'est aussi
elle a une vidéo d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup Alain évidemment
continuer cette émission spéciale
réforme des retraites dans 20 minutes
débat dans le club sur ces émotions de
censure qui seront mis en vote cet
après-midi et on continue à en parler
avec l'invité qui va me succéder c'est
Laurent jacobelli merci alors
[Applaudissements]